[Music]
democrats excuses for breaking their own
rules somehow getting even more pathetic
la mayor eric garcetti got busted over
this maskless photo we took with magic
johnson at the nfc
championship game he was one of three
democrats defying an indoor mask mandate
that says you have to cover up unless
actively eating or drinking garcetti
finally getting asked about it and
channeling the bill clinton didn't
inhale excuse me i wore my mask the
entire game and i when people ask for a
photograph i hold my breath and i put it
here and people could see that there's a
zero percent chance of infection from
that if i'll take personal
responsibility and if it makes you and
everybody else happier even the
photographs with people where i'm
holding my breath literally for two
seconds i won't even do that
and if liberals it's unbelievable
scroll back i miss that sentence
and if liberals are concerned about
garcetti putting people at risk don't
worry he has it all figured out
if you want you know bring medical
evidence to me or something that well if
you hold your breath with us off you're
really endangering people i get it i
won't wear it i won't pull it down for
two seconds anymore that's easy but it
to me it is crystal clear that nobody
has been endangered by that and i'm
trying to model the good behavior of
making sure we wear this entire game my
goodness all right
and while democrats don't think it's
wrong to break their own mask rules just
look at what they're doing to kids all
across america in some virginia schools
students are reportedly being threatened
with 10-day suspensions for defying mass
mandates and potential trespassing
charges if they don't cover up just
listen to what one school official is
saying
until you arrive your children will be
held in an in-school restriction
situation here at school it's important
that i point out to you that they are
not allowed on campus or on loudoun
county public school property
starting tomorrow it will be considered
trespassing
so jesse trespassing arrest kids in
cages
kids in cages if they try to arrest
sophie and ellie i'm gonna make a living
hell out of that i wish i had kids so i
could go to school and yeah it's too
late greg yeah get a bottle of wine
light a candle tonight that's a scary
prospect for her yes for the kids yes um
i'm getting a kick out of the press
basically accusing the la mayor of
trying to kill magic johnson yes
aides didn't kill magic i think the cron
isn't gonna kill magic you can't like
get you can't kill someone standing next
to someone right that's not gonna kill
you people would have tried to kill me
by now and that would have happened
i don't understand this thing though
why doesn't he just say i was eating
pigs in a blanket
my mask was down i was having beer why
does he have to lie like a child now
everybody knows he's a stone cold liar
that's so stupid and we're all worried
about the la laker point guard there was
like 70 000 people in that stadium with
no maps on but magic johnson might die
come on also um i held my breath so how
has fauchy not told us to start doing
that
hold your breath for 15 seconds to stop
this i never heard just if we all stop
breathing this thing will never jump
over a crack
exactly i mean listen
if that works why are we kissing each
other yeah why hasn't he banned sex i
mean we're all rocking around with masks
on outside all day and then we all go
home and sleep together i think that's
probably spreading coronavirus we should
go celibate for 15 days to slow down
speak for yourself
dana uh you claimed before the show
started uh that you had some kind of
theory i have a theory but i'm gonna
wind up to it oh that's all right so
sorry to bring it up like with uh
so magic johnson yes like with other
people that might have an
immuno-compromised condition
he has the ability and the right and the
responsibility to take care of himself
both newsom and garcetti said that magic
johnson asked for the picture um
magic johnson doesn't have a mask on
and if that's
so it's like that's not
if you have an immune immune problem i i
respect that but i have the vaccine you
have the vaccines great you're going to
have to have the responsibility is yours
um and we can tr we can't all protect
all vulnerable people magic johnson
seems to me like he felt very
comfortable there the best thing to
happen to gavin newsom
is mayor garcetti yeah because he made
gavin newsom not look even as ridiculous
as he was if you ran what garcetti just
said through the joe rogan podcast test
on holding your breath i mean imagine
they try to cancel yeah they try to
cancel joe rogan over all that nonsense
um theory and then he says if it would
make you happy yes okay you want my
theory no i like that if you were right
about it making me happy it was like
shut up and make me happy you're the
lead if we right if you're not following
the rules neither are you right also
what would make me happy is if you
followed the science exactly that would
make me very happy my theory is this i
think that the president and his team
this is theory i have no
i think that they are trying to wait to
the state of the union on march first
for him to make some sort of
announcement like denmark finland and
everyone else has done that now he has
crushed the virus and we can return to
normal and the cdc now has said that the
masks can come off and the vaccines
mandates don't have to be in place i
would just urge them if you are thinking
of waiting another month for that i
wouldn't do that
because as you're seeing the schools
people are furious yeah already it's
crazy geraldo i mean trespassing that's
up to 12 months in jail and a hefty uh
fine
this is i don't know if it was you who
said this but these gloves are coming
off and there is a masked civil war
brewing right was it you said that
what's wrong
i thought i thought you were having a
stroke
i don't know i'm not good i'm not going
to melt the mouth by the way anybody
just melt the mouth with you have to go
go to a clinic immediately afterwards i
beg your pardon
you go master message you'll never
forget it
uh yeah you know i i think i think this
about uh mass mandates and and kids
being uh being punished uh i was a
anti-war protester during the day i got
arrested twice in washington dc and one
of the times i got arrested i was kept
overnight and i worried that it would
affect my admission to the bar there
were real consequences and then i did it
again so
my point is if there is an act of civil
disobedience and that's what it is if
you're a kid in the school and you know
the school has a mass mandate and you
defy the school if you take that stand
that's fine i'm all for activism but you
have to understand that there are
consequences to activism that's why it
is uh you know an act of sacrifice in a
sense to make a stand but if you're
gonna make a stand kid
be ready to get isolated in the
auditorium there are there are not any
rules there are consequences that's the
biggest
rule of all that if you break the rules
there are consequences oh i'd hate to be
a this is the time where i would not
want to be a police officer and have to
enforce rules like these like the
selling of single cigarettes where did
that lead to somebody's death what
happens when you start chasing around
kids because they're not wearing masks
well you know i'm not sure what the rule
is right now the county judge is
deciding that in virginia i mean you've
got the governor saying there's an
executive order you don't have to wear
the mask supported by the fact that the
governor was elected over you know a guy
who was well known in virginia a former
governor and uh you know you've got the
school boards now who the people and the
parents obviously don't care for and for
good reason
it appears so i mean i'd be comfortable
you know just having my child go there
without a mask and you want it you want
to arrest my child you want to arrest my
child it's not going to happen number
one
you're not that's not they can't do it
they can't start arresting these kids
what if they're 12 years old they're
going to take them to juvies also they
can't arrest all of them in addition in
addition to all of that you've got
you've got the the the government who
can't figure out what they're saying and
i go back to the beginning of the
segment and that is he says there's zero
chance of getting an infection because
i'm holding my breath like clinton
doesn't inhale and garcetti doesn't
exhale and he says but i put the mask on
his exact words so that there's no
spread well if there's zero chance of it
spreading if you're holding your breath
how why are you putting your mask back
on so that there's no spread i mean
they're just stupid they just make this
stuff up and they just are convinced
that they're better than the rest of us
i'm fed up with them everyone's fed up
with them and we're going to talk about
the truckers later i i think the country
is fed up with all of them i think the
president makes a mistake if he waits
until uh the state of the union so
you're you're uh encouraging people to
break the rules no no no i'm encouraging
people to follow the executive order of
the governor and the rules the united
states supreme court has made it clear
you as an employer cannot direct that uh
businesses with over a hundred masked
your employees this is a school okay
i know it's a school but what i'm
telling you they haven't decided about
schools yet and there is less chance of
children being infected or passing the
infection around so stop with this
nonsense and let's get back to living
our kids have suffered enough they have
they're going to be suffering at the
hands of the russians and the chinese
because they're behind them and you know
what it's all nonsense because the
charter schools i say the private
schools
the leaders are too cowardly to declare
that it's over yeah this is why you have
to do it you just said something just
casually about if more people do it it
is true
you watch how the looters were able to
overtake stores because there were so
many of them in a lawful and much more
congenial manner a group of people
coming in not wearing masks aren't going
to get it right you can't arrest
everybody you can't arrest everybody
that's when it's over they're not
arrested they're descending to detention
arresting criminal trespass is a crime
kids have so many things to deal with
yeah in life they're isolated
back off yeah that's true they have a
lot of other kids they don't need this
problem though because just remember
they're on your side
sorry all right hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else